the other aspect related to White
Christian nationalism in this country
is Tucker Carlson
who hosts a weekly racist fireside chat
on Fox News the highest rated program in
the history of the network hosted by
Tucker Carlson who has said that
immigrants didn't delineate between
illegal immigrants or legal immigrants
he just said immigrants make our country
poorer and dirtier
he said it he has said white supremacy
is a myth it doesn't exist he's now
shifted they're really the only racism
is anti-white racism
and he went on a this Jag last night
about the new crisis in America
they're gonna they're gonna gin this up
this new crisis is white racism
to his aging out audience filled with
lulling to sleep octogenarians
convincing an elder population that
there is a new crisis in America
watch this
so clearly Democratic party needs a new
emergency at least until we start
sending ground troops to Ukraine and the
population becomes suitably hysterical
again
so because they need an emergency they
found one and the new emergency turns
out to be the old emergency which is
white racism now unfortunately for the
Democratic party white racism is one
commodity
like cedar boards that's getting harder
to find very few unarmed black men are
killed by white cops these days where's
George Floyd when you need them so
instead in a pinch they've settled for
an unarmed black man killed by black
cops which they have informed us
nevertheless despite all appearances is
still the product of white racism and
Barack Obama enthusiastically agrees
this is Barack Obama's Lane
he was elected president twice on this
kind of stuff so he immediately jumped
into the middle of the Memphis tragedy
to remind us that white middle-class
Republicans did this blood is on their
hands Selma Dr King Rodney King Trayvon
Martin they're all the fruit of white
supremacy
not the fruit of white supremacy Tucker
how is it the disproportionate killing
of unarmed black men in this country is
not a byproduct of white supremacy and
systemic racism in our country
you vile putrid white supremacist
who still is propped up by advertisers
on Fox News
where's George Floyd when you need him
he declares
this is wretched reprehensible Behavior
a disgusting display
sponsored
by whomever
by the my pillow guy I guess and then
this crack about until we send ground
troops to Ukraine as though this is our
war
as though we've been invaded by Russia
or as though we've invaded Ukraine
it's all a play to create a frenzy and a
panic in his audience
as he declares the new crisis to be
white racism he's actually creating the
new crisis
on his program
listen I've talked a lot about Tucker
Carlson the googly-eyed feather duster
the haircut the soft skin smooth brain
and if it weren't for the fact that he
has the most ratings the greatest most
popular show in the history of Fox News
and Fox News Far and Away gets better
ratings than any other Cable News
Network if it weren't for that the fact
that people listen to him people trust
him people take his conspiracy theories
as fact
they take him at his word that he's
correct
you you could you could throw a suit or
a bow tie on a racist they're still a
racist just because he doesn't have a
skinhead
and Nazi tattoos doesn't make him a new
Nazi it's exactly what he is and he
thrives on it he profits off of it
and he has the ear of the only declared
candidate for president and the
Republican Party Donald Trump
he has regular text conversations with
Alex Jones
and he's now patterning his show
almost in I mean Sans selling vitamins
and supplements it's the same thing
this is dangerous
and we need to still be aware of it we
need to still keep on top of this and
keep it in the Forefront of our minds
and not just let it go away as well he's
just loopy in conspiracy theory he has
an audience
he rallies support people uh quote him
people cite him in their manifestos
after they commit violence
we need to stay on top of this
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore you
can find me online I am perpetually on
the internet uh you can subscribe to my
YouTube show dollar more daily just
search my name follow me on social media
I am on Twitter Instagram and Tick Tock
at dollar more and I'd love for you to
subscribe to my twice weekly podcast
called I doubt it wherever you find
podcasts